with Donald Trump getting federally
indicted there have been a number of
people coming out of the woodwork to
make the case that the best thing for
the country right now would be for
President Joe Biden to step in and
pardon Donald Trump for the crimes that
he's accused of the arguments tend to
center around this idea of healing the
country or assuring people that the
Department of Justice and law
enforcement in this country apply the
law equally and they're not operating in
any sort of political fashion
there have been a number of people in
media making this case and I came across
this one op-ed in the hill I wanted to
rebut having to do with this topic it's
called the nine reasons Biden should
pardon Trump it's written by chip Muir
so I thought it would be good to go
through these arguments one by one to go
through all of Chip's nine points and
see if any of these arguments are
convincing so reason number one that
provides is that first historical
precedence in the aftermath of Watergate
suggests that a pardon would be the best
outcome for the nation on August 9 1974
President Nixon resigns the presidency
in the wake of Watergate one on
September 8th President Gerald Ford
pardoned him the gesture curtailed the
acrimony of over continued Watergate
Fallout and started the process of
moving forward though Nixon felt he was
innocent of criminal conduct and should
not have to accept a pardon the pardon
ended his legal Jeopardy and allowed him
to acknowledge he should have handled
the situation better in either case a
humbling yet gracious Lifeline allowed
America to move forward
well just because it happened once
before that one president's pardoned
another that doesn't mean that it has to
happen again and it certainly doesn't
mean that it was the right move it
doesn't mean that it was right for a
Ford to do so and also you have to
remember that Ford and Nixon were in the
same party Ford was of course Nixon's VP
for a time so there was a political
reason to Pardon as well to protect the
interests of the Republican party at the
time now you can make the case that the
pardon did allow the country to heal
from Watergate and move forward but I
would argue that we would also have had
that healing had Nixon been charged and
gone through the criminal process
whether he was found guilty or not then
once it was all said and done even
though it would have taken a little bit
longer sure then we could realize that
okay justice has been served in this
case Nixon was treated just like any
other criminal defendant would be and
the jury came up with their decision the
judge carried out the sentence and Bam
justice has been served now we can move
on as a country from this Watergate
scandal that ultimately still would have
happened it may have taken a little bit
longer but that would have been a
totally fine course of action in my mind
also we have to remember that Gerald
Ford didn't win a term of his own he
lost to Jimmy Carter in the 1976
Presidential election suggesting that
maybe the American people wanted to see
Nixon prosecuted instead of getting this
pardon
now we continue uh second it is
historically unprecedented for an
American president to prosecute his
likely opponent the U.S has had six
presidential election rematches
including the John Quincy Adams Andrew
Jackson rematch of an alleged stolen
election regardless of personal belief
over legitimate legitimacy of the
indictment the action itself is
unprecedented Republicans are sure to
and should use this indictment against
Biden to show a weak and continuously
weakening presidents trying to use his
power to slant an election a pardon
takes away this talking point as Biden
would be using his official part in
power to avoid handicapping his likely
opposition well I gotta say it's also
unprecedented to have a president like
Trump who didn't care one iota about the
rule of law in this country who time and
time again showed his depravity and his
corruption Biden also for his part is
staying out of this and he's saying that
uh he's not going to talk about the case
it's the doj after all that is
Prosecuting him there's no evidence that
Biden himself has anything to do with
the charging decision and if Biden does
pardon Trump then Republicans ultimately
are not going to be gracious and kind
they're just going to keep attacking him
they're going to talk about the other
issues like inflation and the culture
War and the border and guns and they'll
continue to criticize Biden it's if
anything going to make Biden look like a
pushover and like he's weak if he
decides to do this and pardon Donald
Trump we continue third Biden would
appear magnanimous as a candidate the
Biden Camp tried to paint him as looking
presidential and restoring Norms reality
has painted a different picture from his
underwater approval ratings net minus 14
weakness among independent voters and
video clips that routinely show
confusion Biden has failed to live up to
the image his campaign wanted to project
but a pardon would be a shockingly
magnanimous gesture Shoring up any such
image problem look if voters are trying
to find the most magnanimous candidates
they're already going to go with Joe
Biden because they know who by is he's
an empathetic person he cares about the
average working-class person whereas
Trump is seen as vindictive and this
egomaniac type if it's a battle about
who is the most magnanimous obviously
Joe biddings going to win that every day
of the week he doesn't have to Pardon
Donald Trump to get a reputation of
being magnanimous for the better person
when it comes to personal values fourth
Biden has his own classified documents
problem he's had documents in his
University of Pennsylvania office and
classified documents in his garage near
his Corvette offering a pardon minimizes
the accusations of double standards at
play this is a false equivalence there
is a world of difference when it comes
to the types of records that both
Presidents had in their possession the
amount of documents and how serious they
were the level of classification that
they had and more importantly Joe Biden
cooperated his lawyers turned over the
documents and questions immediately no
questions asked whereas Donald Trump
lied to the authorities repeatedly and
refused to hand them back even when
faced with a subpoena fifth Americans
are rightfully concerned about the
overreach of federal agencies and
political matters expect president Trump
to vigorously defend himself with
accusations of political motivations at
trial while it may or may not help a
trial it will work as a political tactic
with the electorate by this logic Barack
Obama should have pardoned Hillary
Clinton and Donald Trump should have
pardoned Democrats like Hunter Biden who
were embroiled and Scandal just pardon
anyone that's being investigated is
apparently the point that's being made
here so it doesn't look like federal
agencies are interfering too much in our
politics what would actually happen if
this was the case was would be that we
would create this sentiment where our
Elites are completely Above the Law we
already have that sentiment here in this
country you would exacerbate that and
you would make it clear that there's a
two-tiered system of justice in this
country one for the elites who are
getting pardons left and right and one
for regular folks who have to go through
the criminal process and maybe found
convicted and sent to jail without the
possibility of getting part of
themselves because they're nobodies
after all sixth in the art of the deal
Trump discussed the Anti-Trust suit his
usfl brought against the NFL and
specifically mentioned how important it
was that the NFL on a daily basis gave
interviews to win in the court of public
opinion president Trump will use every
day in the run-up to trial and at trial
to rail against the corruption of Biden
and his doj and FBI by offering a pardon
and not providing Trump with the
spotlight of a trial President Biden
would take away Trump's ability to
demonstrate how unfairly without
precedent he has been treated by
offering a pardon President Biden would
take away Trump's most significant
campaign opportunity his trial I gotta
tell you Trump is going to be able to
capture the media's attention no matter
what no matter if this trial is taking
place or not he is going to be able to
use all of this stuff to his political
Advantage when it comes to his base at
least no matter what even if this case
is dropped because you gotta remember
he's also going to have other trials to
concern himself with including trials
that are outside the purview of
President Joe Biden like the one out of
York for example and the one out of
Georgia that's likely going to come in
the next few weeks so even if Biden was
to do this for the sake of not making
the trial a focal point in the election
well Trump could just talk about the
other trials that he's dealing with and
you're not going to accomplish getting
this out of the campaign Focus just by
pardoning Donald Trump is the point
seventh the converse of President Biden
looking magnanimous and offering the
pardon is that Trump would potentially
look weak innocent men do not need
pardons the pardon is a lifeline and so
on
and it's the same concern that Nixon
expressed during his month of purgatory
after resigning the pardon would make
him look guilty when he wanted public
exoneration accepting a pardon would be
the logical and rational decision for
Trump but Democrats can spin it to say
that Trump needed Biden's generous
pardon to avoid a certain conviction and
imprisonment now this one of course is
just silly because we know that if Biden
pardons Trump then Trump would just turn
around and make the argument that look
the Biden administration had this flimsy
case against me they knew that I was
going to beat the charges so strongly in
court that they had no choice but to
Pardon Me and his supporters will eat
that up they're not going to think that
Trump is somehow weak and presumably
guilty because he accepted a pardon
that's just not how Trump and his
supporters operate also chip writes
about how innocent men don't need
pardons well innocent men also aren't
convicted of crimes at least not
typically of course there are some cases
where that happens but generally
speaking innocent men are convicted of
crimes so if you want to paint Trump as
a criminal and that's I suppose the
strategy for going forward politically
just let the process play out because it
looks like this is a rock solid case
against him and Trump is likely going to
end up convicted here eighth Trump might
moot the issue by declining the pardon
Trump is a fighter he will want to
vindicate himself in both the court of
law and the court of public opinion he
might see a pardon as denying him that
opportunity making it very difficult for
him to accept the pardon by offering the
pardon knowing full well that it might
not be accepted by Trump Biden puts
Trump in the difficult position of
either losing his chance at public
Vindication due to the generosity of his
opponent or risking a trial and
conviction after a way out had been
offered in this sense offering a pardon
is a no risk proposition for Biden we're
really grasping at straws at this point
Trump is potentially going to spend the
rest of his life in prison over these
charges there's a real possibility of
that at the very least even if you think
it's unlikely because he's a former
president these are serious charges and
there's going to likely be some
consequences for them he's terrified of
that he wouldn't reject the pardon
because he knows that there's a serious
possibility of him ending up in jail
rejecting the pardon would make no sense
politically because he could just like I
said use this to his advantage and say
that
it was he was pardoned because of the
flimsy case against him he would accept
it in a second right because that would
just be one thing he doesn't have to
worry about and he wouldn't think that
it would be any sort of liability for
himself in the 2024 election he would
see it as Democrats admitting to the
fact that there was a Witch Hunt against
him ninth and last the progressive wing
of the democratic party has spent years
trying to destroy Trump and they have
been beaten each time the progressive
Wing would be furious if Trump escapes
their clutches because Trump was
pardoned but Biden's polling with
Independence is deeply underwater and
these swing voters are also polling at a
net minus 55 points on the question of
whether the nation is on the right or
the wrong track offering a pardon
knowing how deeply unpopular the move
would be with progressives would
demonstrate that Biden is not beholden
to that wing of his party alternatively
failing to offer a pardon would be
further proof that he is beholden to the
most extreme voices in the Democratic
party and bog him down even further with
Independence well I certainly disagree
with the premise when it comes to this
one because because progressives have
had their wins against Donald Trump over
the years from the two impeachments to
defeating him at The Ballot Box in 2020
to taking the house in 2018 in the
senate in 2020 and then fighting off the
Red Wave in 2022 also I'm not sure the
progressives are more in favor of
Prosecuting Trump than generic Democrats
are I'd like to see the polling on that
one but the most important thing from
this ninth Point here is that you're
maybe ignoring the other side of the
equation you can say that okay it's
possible that Biden will pick up some
independence from pardoning Trump but he
couldn't he also lose some of those
progressives you're talking about if he
decides to do this couldn't some
progressives decide to vote third party
or vote for a challenger to Biden in the
primary or stay home altogether you have
to calculate that also into your
equation so overall those are the nine
arguments I don't think any of them make
sense or are all that convincing if you
want to show that no person is above the
law no matter how rich or powerful they
may be then you have to prosecute when
you have reasonable suspicion that
crimes were committed otherwise you are
giving Trump and the people who come
after him the green light to do whatever
they want because they think that
they'll get away with it and even if
they don't entirely get away with it
then they'll get a pardon and
effectively ultimately get away with it
so I wonder if Trump was accused of more
serious violent crimes whether people
like chipmur would be making these exact
same points because they all would apply
right and maybe it's taking it to an
absurd level to say that everyone would
be calling for Biden to Pardon Trump if
Trump had committed a crime like murder
or something like that but it shouldn't
be even viewed through that lens it
should just be viewed as their crimes on
the books and if anyone no matter who
you are commits them is accused of
committing them you're going to be
taking through the criminal process and
treated just like anybody else all right
we're going to go to a break now but
we'll be back with the final segment of
the David packman show after these
commercial messages thank you
we've talked on the show about how
internet service providers have been
logging everything their customers do
online and selling that data tech
companies use trackers in websites and
apps to collect your data you can Shield
yourself from all of it by using a VPN
every time you connect to the internet
the VPN I use is private internet access
it's the only VPN that has proven
multiple times in court they do not log
your activity our sponsor private
internet access hides my IP address
prevents big Tech from being able to
paint a picture of who I am and what I
do online and it works for all of your
favorite streaming platforms like
Netflix and Hulu to access shows and
movies normally only available in other
countries it's one of the only vpns that
works for peer-to-peer file sharing and
the best part is you can protect
unlimited devices with just one account
going online without private internet
access is like leaving your phone
unattended in a crowded room anyone can
just take a glance my audience gets 83
percent off that's just 203 a month plus
four extra months for free go to
piavpn.com Pacman the link is down below